vous avez la parole monsieur le
président retailleau
pour attendre parole de dix minutes
félicitations fini
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur président du sénat cher gérard
larcher monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les membres du
gouvernement chers collègues
parlementaires députés ou sénateurs
le président de la république a souhaité
provoqué cette réunion du congrès ici à
versailles et cette réunion de nos deux
assemblées
c'est un moment important parce que
c'est un moment rare
un moment qui nous oblige à une certaine
hauteur comme l'a dit à quelques
instants ici même le président de la
république à la hauteur d'abord de ce
lieu chargé d'histoire d'une histoire
longue qui s'enracine dans une culture
notre culture la culture française que
le monde nous envie temps une histoire
aussi récente dramatiquement récente
nous étions bien sûr quelques uns ici
lorsque le congrès s'est réuni à
quelques jours du massacre du bataclan
et à mon tour je voudrais avoir une
pensée émue pour toutes les victimes de
la barbarie islamiste
pour celles et ceux qui encore portent
dans leur chair et dans leur esprit des
blessures profondes
bien sûr qu'ils doivent aujourd'hui nous
inciter à une action encore plus
déterminé ce moment aussi doit nous
porter à la bonne hauteur un moment
paradoxal un moment paradoxal parce que
l'espérance qui a fait naître cette
élection présidentielle auprès de
certains de nos compatriotes
cette espérance contraste aussi avec un
silence mes chers collègues le silence
de celles et ceux qui n'ont pas voté le
silence de celles et de ceux qui ne
veulent plus participer parce que bien
souvent les grandes douleurs sont
muettes
c'est d'abord la douleur du déclassement
économique le chômage de masse
l'ascenseur social bloqué c'est aussi la
douleur de la dépossession culturel
enfouie sous tend de non dits après tant
de recul et nous en payons aujourd'hui
le prix fort à travers des poussées
communautariste et leurs pendants
symétrique des replis identitaires alors
oui ce moment nous oblige et il nous
oblige tous ils nous obligent touche
pour faire en sorte que notre discussion
parlementaire dans les jours à venir ne
soit pas seulement l'expression d'un
entre soi mais soit leur commencement de
la construction d'un entre nous pour
qu'enfin on puisse renouer le fil de
cette conversation civique avec une
france silencieuse qui attend qu'on lui
parle qui attend surtout que on agisse
pas seulement avec des mots de façon
concrète
il faut désormais passer à l'exercice
pratique cette france silencieuse qui
attend que on relève le défi le défi de
ses crises ses fractures qui déchire le
tissu national et il faudra beaucoup
plus que des deux me réforme
peut-être une réforme institutionnelle
mais il faudra d'abord le courage et le
courage ne résident aucune institution
le courage ce sont les femmes et les
hommes qui au cours de l'histoire dans
toujours porter et il faudra
bien évidemment plus que des réformes
même plus peut-être que des
transformations des révolutions si je
veux utiliser un titre désormais célèbre
3 révolution une révolution d'abord
économiques contre le chômage de masse
bien sûr il faut faire sauter les
verrous
il faut baisser vis-à-vis nos
partenaires européens
le coût du travail les deux vont de pair
il faut rééquilibrer la sphère publique
par rapport à la sphère privée
cette addiction de l'état pour la
dépense publique nous emmène dans le mur
l'an prochain monsieur le premier
ministre la dette atteindra sans doute
100 % de la richesse annuelle produite
par tous les français
c'est une banque une bombe sociale qui
menace de faire imploser
notre modèle social vous devrez nous
expliquer dès demain où sont les baisses
de dépenses publiques une révolution
aussi territoriales on ne peut pas dire
que l'unique avenir de la france mais
chers collègues nous que vous veniez ce
soir uniquement ce chemin qui passe par
les grandes métropoles mondialisée il y
avons cherché à l'archet cette france
d'à côté cette france périphérique que
nous portons aussi dans chacune de nos
circonscriptions au département alors
oui peut-être faut-il une conférence
territoriale
mais alors il faudra nous dire quelle
est votre vision de cette belle idée de
l'aménagement du territoire il faudra
choisir entre l'amputation de la liberté
communal et les landes une nouvelle
décentralisation d'un nouvel acte de
décentralisation
parce que la france est d'abord des
territoires mona ozouf parler de la
france comme une composition française
et puis une autre révolution la
révolution civique
les terroristes islamistes nous ont
désigné cela n'est pas nous
comme leur ennemi et nous leur devons la
détermination la plus totale ici comme
là-bas
ces déterminations bien sûr elle passe
par un arsenal militaire policier
judiciaire
mais elle passe aussi par une réponse
civique par ce creuset que doit
redevenir l'école creuser la
transmission bien sûr mais aussi par la
reconstruction de la force de l'autorité
de l'état la loi de la république sur
tout le territoire
aucun de ces territoires aucune parcelle
doit être abandonnée pas même monsieur
le premier ministre la za de notre dame
des landes
et si vous me le permettez cette réponse
civique doit aussi doit aussi
s'accompagner d'une lutte contre les
communautarismes
parce que les communautarismes déchire
aussi notre tissu social
évidemment et permettez moi de vous dire
que nous sommes fiers de ce qui est
l'adn de la république française que
nous avons tous en partage
l'universalisme mais l'universalisme
l'universalisme s'anéantit lui même
quand ils ne croient plus en l'universel
quand il pense que ses propres valeurs
universelles ne pourrait convenir qu'à
certains territoires et bien bien sûr
nous portons en commun toutes ces
valeurs
monsieur le premier ministre dans les
semaines qui viennent nous nous verrons
soyez sûr que si vous choisissez ce
chemin escarpé
ce chemin difficile du redressement
français nous serons disponibles pour
appuyer vos propositions pour les
améliorer mais bien sûr que nous serons
aussi une opposition vigilante
ne nous demandez pas d' abdiquer notre
liberté d'abdiquer nos convictions
refusé cette tentation hégémonique
il serait pas bonne ni pour votre
gouvernement ni d'ailleurs pour votre
majorité
ensemble nous pouvons travailler en vous
rappelant que la seule loi qui compte la
grande loi de la cité la grande loi de
la république c'est celle à laquelle on
parvient
grâce au débat pas la pensée unique
grâce aux 10 sentiment c'est ce qu'il
fonde l'idée même de la démocratie et
c'est ce que nous ferons
bien sûr notre seule ligne de conduite
sera inspiré par l'intérêt général et
l'intérêt des français par la haute idée
aussi que nous nous faisons de la france
que nous aimons tous quels que soient
nos histoires personnelles
quelles que soient nos trajectoires
partisane simone veil que si tu es la
philosophe le président de république à
quelques instants disait un jour il faut
donner aux français quelque chose a aimé
et il faut d'abord leur donner à aimer
la france
eh bien monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les membres du
gouvernement chers collègues députés et
sénateurs
c'est en reconnaissant ce principe
démocratique
c'est en le reconnaissant profondément
et en faisant en prenant en compte nos
voix parfois divergentes que vous
permettrez à la voix de la france est à
la fois de tous les français d'exprimer
et de s'exprimer
bien sûr au coeur de nous a semblé c'est
ce que nous souhaitons tous aujourd'hui
en ce jour solennel
vive la république française et vive la
france merci une sur retailleau
[Applaudissements]